اذا وقال محمد عثمان محمد محمد قائد منطقه
البحر الاحمر العسكري الجزيره ان عمليه
اجلاء رعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه من
العاصمه الخرطوم تتم عبر ميناء ومطار
بورسودان شرق البلاد مؤكدا التزام الجيش
السوداني بتوفير الحمايه لهم منذ تحركهم
من الخرطوم وحتى وصولهم الى مدينه بورسودا
هذا وقال قائد منطقه البحر الاحمر
العسكريه لجزيره ان الجيش السوداني يواجه
تحديات كبيره في عمليه تامين الرعايه من
الجنسيات المختلفه منذ اقامتهم في مدينه
بورسودان وصولا الى اكتمال اجلائهم
هناك تحديات في عمليه الاجلاء هي في وزاره
التامين حرصنا الكامل من خلال التوجيهات
الصادره من قياده القوات الشعب المسلحه
بان يتم التامين كامل خلال عمليه الاجلاء
وايضا بعد وجودهم في مدينه بورسودان يتم
التامين
لكل كل الاشقاء المطلوبهم حاجات ان عمليه
التامين هي عمليه هي يعني ما سهله يكون في
جهد اضافي بالنسبه لقواتنا